cuba dans moins de deux heures le pape
jean paul ii atterrira à laval pour un
voyage historique la réconciliation
entre l'église catholique et le régime
de fidel castro
fausse alerte au vaccin contre
l'hépatite b les troubles ressentis par
certains enfants n'avaient rien
d'alarmant et ne remet pas en cause
l'efficacité de ce traitement
les chômeurs tombe de rester mobilisés
déçu par les déclarations lionel jospin
la manière dont les français après en
exclusion a changé en quarante ans de
l'abbé pierre mon resto du coeur enquête
dans ce journal
les professionnels du disque sont réunis
à cannes il publie la liste des
meilleures ventes avec des valeurs sûres
mais aussi des surprises
voilà monsieur bonsoir c'est à 22h heure
française dans moins de deux heures qu
aura lieu l'événement historique
l'avion spécial du pape jean paul ii
s'est envolé ce matin de rome
direction la havane pour la grande
réconciliation entre l'église catholique
et fidel castro après presque quarante
années de régime communiste qui avait
pratiquement tenter d'éradiquer le
catholicisme dans l'île chassant les
prêtres vie dans les églises c'est donc
un voyage éminemment politique
sur place dans les rues de la havane la
population se prépare un accueil que
l'on dit déjà triomphale sur place à 25
ans
la route de l'aéroport est un prête pour
accueillir le pape décorée aux couleurs
du vatican et de cuba par ci par là des
employés de l'état met une dernière main
aux dispositifs place de la révolution
jean paul ii sera la surprise de
découvrir derrière ce slogan
révolutionnaire un christ monumental
grande première à la havane
le pape n'est attendu qu'en fin d'après
midi 23 heures heure de paris il n'ya
donc encore personnes sur le parcours
mais dans les points de rassemblement
les gens commençaient à arriver en fin
de matinée ambiance semble-t-il plutôt
joyeuse
certains bus commençaient également à
charger mais pour le moment c'est
surtout la guerre des chapelets chacun
aura le sien gratis chacun rosie son
ballon que des enfants gonfle dans les
églises
en attendant le départ pour l'accueil du
pape très organisée conjointement par
les paroisses et l'état sur le mode
soviétique
tous les quartiers de la havane ont eu
un espace à fait quitté depuis europe où
jusqu'à la résidence du plaignant
annonce entendons-nous ces prêts d'ici
on s'entend et drapeaux et des ballots
et haut parleurs installés en haut des
églises donne des consignes aux fidèles
cela peut paraître anodin mais dans un
régime comme celui ci c'est une
révolution dans la révolution
autre concession du gouvernement les
écoles ont fermé exceptionnellement
aujourd'hui à 12h30 de façon à ce que
les petits puissent te aussi et
-surtout- accueillir jean paul ii un
syndrome bonsoir à moins de trois heures
de l'arrivée de jean paul ii l'émotion
l'attention sont-elles perceptible à la
havane oui écouter on a vraiment
l'impression de vivre un moment
historique dans une ambiance tout à fait
extraordinaire on a l'impression que le
pays
en quelques jours c'est désinhibés par
exemple il ya encore une dizaine de
jours vous voyez très peu d' affiches du
pape comme si les gens avaient un petit
peu peur de s'afficher comme ça comme
catholiques et bien aujourd'hui on a
pratiquement dans toutes les maisons en
tout cas toutes les maisons qui se
disent chrétienne et puis pouvait-on
imaginer aussi franchement regardez ça
ça c'est le journal du parti communiste
le grade mas poux étant imaginer que sa
couverture à sa première page en entier
serait consacré cet événement alain la
visite de jean paul ii à cuba peut-elle
avoir
disons les mêmes conséquences politiques
comme certains de ses voyages en europe
de l'est je pense à la pologne
oui côté c'est la grande question qu'on
se pose surtout de l'autre côté de du
détroit de floride aux états unis mais
je crois d'abord qu'il faut dire que
cuba n'est pas la pologne si l'église a
toujours eu beaucoup moins influence par
exemple avant la révolution il n'y avait
que 10 % de de pratiquants et puis le
pape n'est pas cuba il est polonais
justement et puis fidel castro n'est pas
jalouse elle skie il bénéficie ici d'un
réel soutien populaire
on le respecte on lui met un on met à
son crédit un certain nombre de
réalisations sociales et puis la fierté
du pays
cela dit vous savez dans ce genre de
régime
quand on en trouve la porte on prend
toujours un risque
on ne sait jamais ce qui va s'engouffrer
derrière merci alain ce voyage est
également l'occasion pour des milliers
de cubains réfugié aux états unis depuis
la révolution en 1959 de revenir dans
l'île de retrouver leurs familles des
dizaines d'avions ont été affrétés dans
l'un d'eux notre reporter philippe
gassot l arrivée à la havane les
réfugiés cubains aux états unis n'en
croient pas leurs yeux
il touche au but après pour certains
trente six années d'exil
aucun pourri mais je n'y crois pas mais
je dois je dois me penser c'est
formidable mais je vais pleurer dans une
minute
un étonnement partagé par le service
d'ordre cubain qui c'est vrai n'a jamais
vu ça le retour des contre
révolutionnaires au pays
les consignes sont bien passées les
contrôles seront légers et presque
amicaux canton retrouvailles
plusieurs charters ont été autorisés par
les états unis pour la circonstance
mais le vol historique qui entaillent
l'embargo est sans aucun doute celui qui
a quitté new york pour un vol direct sur
la vanne du jamais vu c'est formidable
j'aurais adoré être sur ce volant c'est
la première fois que je vois ça dans ma
vie un avion à destination de la havane
j'espère qu'il y en aura d'autres dans
l'aéroport kennedy de new york
450 personnes sont au départ prête à
toutes les émotions avec dans les
bagages toutes sortes d'objets de
vêtements de médicaments à donner à ceux
qui en manquent
de l'autre côté il ya aussi les preuves
de dernière minute le coup de massue 26
visas seront refusées par les cubains
cette femme partira donc seule son mari
n'est pas sur la liste
c'est une grande déception pour les
autres difficile de parler d'un vol sans
histoire il partage la même
ils vont voir le pape est aussi retrouvé
leur passé d'abord j'ai envie d'aller
voir mes cousins que je ne connais pas
et aussi d'aller voir la ville où ma
mère a grandi le vol impossible est
arrivé il leur a demandé quand quitté
d'autorisation à washington est aussi et
sens de l'intervention du seigneur si
l'on se contente de survoler l'histoire
fidel castro apparaît comme un farouche
adversaire de la religion mais c'est
oublier un peu vite son enfance et son
éducation chez les jésuites alain de
chalon surtout cette image celle du
guérillero par bus révolutionnaire
radical qui va transformer son pays en
allié fidèle et zélé de l'union
soviétique amis de khrouchtchev brejnev
et consorts un marxiste léniniste pur et
dur at et bien sûr la réalité est
peut-être un peu plus nuancé regardez
bien cette photo qui date de 1958
le jeune chef de la guérilla de la
sierra maestra qu'il était alors porte
sa médaille de baptême au cou et dans la
sierra il assiste à la messe dite par
l'aumônier de la guérilla le père
sardegna sq qui l'a fait venir auprès de
lui le père sardinha ce qui était avec
nous avait le grade de commandant de thé
ces étoiles de commandant il les avait
sur sa soutane vert-olive il faisait les
baptêmes est le parrain c'était toujours
fidèle
rien de vraiment étonnant pire elle a
été élevée par une mère profondément
catholique surprenant compression du
lider maximo devant les députés de
l'assemblée populaire elle allait
toujours à la messe et tout ça elle a dû
énormément souffrir de ne plus pouvoir y
aller
d'ailleurs maman castro avait mis ses
trois garçons fidèles en tête dans ce
collège des jésuites le meilleur du pays
aujourd'hui transformée en école
militaire
la pré négociation ce en étant discret
que j'ai pu avoir avec lui il peut pas
se défaire de cette éducation religieuse
il a d'ailleurs des souvenirs très
précis de de cette formation est à lire
aussi la connaissance qu'il a de
l'évangile et quand on demande
aujourd'hui un fidèle si les croyants
ils répondent en bon ancien élève des
jésuites
si je dis je ne crois pas
la team je fais de la peine nous croyons
si je dis je crois fait de la peine aux
non croyants alors qu'elle opérait alors
croyants ou pas fidèle le
révolutionnaire jean paul ii au terme de
sa visite en sera peut-être plus
en france fausse alerte au vaccin contre
l'hépatite b qui aurait été mal dosé
provoquant des troubles chez un certain
nombre d'enfants vaccinés en 1995
environ 175 milles en fait il ne s'agit
pas d'un mauvais dosage du vaccin mais
d'une injection trop importante du
produit de toute façon les réactions
constatées chez certains enfants
n'avaient rien d'alarmant jean daniel
flaysakier et pierre moscovitch ça ça
les fatigue n'est pas question de
prendre de risques c'était ton 1995 un
clip choc pour inciter les pré
adolescents à se faire vacciner contre
l'hépatite b ions de maladie
actuellement transmissibles surtout par
voie sexuelle 3000 nouveaux cas par an
cent mille porteurs de virus en france
lors de la deuxième vague de vaccination
en 95 ch et quelques dizaines
d'adolescents l'injection d'un vaccin
entraîne quelques effets secondaires un
peu plus fréquentes d'habitude nous
aimons tête et douleurs au point
d'injection des effets qui disparaissent
en quelques heures et qui n'auront
aucune conséquence utilisé sans problème
aux états unis et aussi dans toute
l'union européenne à l'exception de la
belgique et de l'espagne
le vaccin est examinée de près
conclusion aucune anomalie
il n'y a en particulier aucun surdosage
du principe actif cause la plus probable
un volume total injecté 1 millilitre
peut-être trop important pour certains
enfants on change rapidement de vaccins
et tout rentre dans l'ordre ce matin
bernard kouchner n'hésitez pas à
désigner ce qui selon lui avait tout
intérêt à monter cet événement en
épingle il ya là une manifestation
parfois sectaire je pèse mes mots
parfois sectaires qui vient parfois d'un
ensemble de sectes contre la vaccination
mais par ailleurs je comprends que les
parents soient inquiets lorsque les
incidents comme cela se développe c'est
pourquoi nous intervenons ce sont des
incidents mineurs mais nous les prenons
très au sérieux
deuxième rumeur abordé ce matin le
vaccin hépatite b serait responsable
d'un certain nombre de cas de sclérose
en plaques
des affirmations faites là encore sans
aucune preuve scientifique
nous n'avons aucun argument ni clinique
ni expérimental ni épidémiologique qui
puisse nous faire penser qu'il ya une
association entre la vaccination
anti-hépatite b les possèdent sclérose
en plaques
les enfants vaccinés en 95 ont
parfaitement bien
l'hépatite b elle a tué encore 3000
personnes
l'an dernier le match d'inauguration du
nouveau stade de france à saint-denis
pouvait se présenter comme une simple
fête du football en fait elle apparaît
déjà comme un casse-tête est un risque
majeur dans la mesure où les employés de
la ratp menacent de faire grève ce
jour-là et le ministre des transports a
prévu à toute fin utile de mettre en
place un service de 700 autres car
réquisitionnées pour la circonstance
pour transporter les 80000 spectateurs
annoncés
philippe visseyrias album big aussi
inutile d'espérer
si vous allez au match france espagne
vous ne garderez pas votre voiture dans
ce parking
nous sommes sur le stade de france il
n'y a que cinq mille places toutes
réservées aux officiels et aux invités
depuis des semaines les autorités le
répète le 28 janvier prenez les
transports en commun la gare rer du
stade de france sera d'ailleurs inauguré
dans quelques jours le problème c'est
que le soir du match
une grève pourrait paralyser métro et
rer les syndicats autonomes de la sncf
appellent à la grève sur les rer b et d
la cgt sur la ligne 13 du métro un
préavis qui pourrait être étendu à
l'ensemble du réseau
leur revendication augmentation
d'effectifs et primes pour les agents
desservant le stade de france un
mouvement social critiquée par le
gouvernement
hier jean pierre chevènement a parlé de
prises d'otages et aujourd'hui on
apprend que jean claude gayssot le
ministre des transports chercherait des
solutions pour contourner la grève
parmi les hypothèses 700 cartes privées
pour transporter 50 mille personnes face
à une telle menace
les syndicats réagissent si
effectivement on temps de régler cette
situation conflictuelle par la mise en
place la mise en service de cars de
substitution au privé ça sera pas
acceptant des bus privés comme transport
de secours en cas de grève
on avait déjà vu ça à marseille lors du
tirage au sort de la coupe du monde mais
là l'opération est d'une tout autre
ampleur 715 sur le chemin du stade
c'est pour le centre régional
d'information routière le cauchemar
assurer des véhicules dans tous les sens
et certainement beaucoup de spectateurs
qui ne seront pas à l'heure dans les
gradins au moment du début du match
grève ou pas grève voici en rouge les
secteurs déconseillé aux automobilistes
le soir du match
trois arrondissements parisiens et
quatre communes de banlieue nord une
situation qui s'avère difficile à gérer
voire impossible si le préavis de grève
est maintenu mais content des
déclarations de lionel jospin qui
n'entend pas augmenter de 15 cents
francs les minima sociaux comme ils
elles le demandent les associations de
chômeurs entend continuer leur action
spectaculaire ce fut le cas aujourd'hui
à l'heure du déjeuner lorsqu'ils
récupèrent les locaux du conseil
économique et social à paris avant d'en
être chassés par la police reportage
damien thévenot josé boulesteix la
méthode est toujours la même un tract
distribué aux journalistes
avec pour seule information un point de
ralliement aujourd'hui c'est à la
bastille sur place des chômeurs mais
surtout des militants d'extrême gauche
et quelques nostalgiques
je fais partie des gens qui ont occupé
la sorbonne le 3 mai 68 en tirant des
tracts consacrée à la répression sur les
étudiants
les gens en banlieue si je vous dis est
ce qu est ce que vous êtes anarchistes
ou pas ensuite tout va très vite
c'est la bousculade il faut arriver sur
place avant les forces de l'ordre pour
beaucoup ces opérations commandos sont
leurs dernières cartouches
c'est la seule façon de se faire
entendre c'est la seule et unique
on a pas d'entreprise n'a pas de salle
unique de se faire en fin d'après-midi
les 150 chômeurs et sympathisants ont
choisi le conseil économique et social
dans le 16e arrondissement après avoir
occupé les assedic au début du mouvement
les militants ont changé de stratégie
désormais ils envahissent des lieux
symboliques toujours devant les caméras
et avec un certain goût pour le
spectacle
une heure et demi d'occupation est
l'épilogué toujours le même évacuation
plus ou moins musclées par les forces de
l'ordre
cet après midi en tout cas les 150
militants ont été interpellés
ce qui ne les empêche pas dû se donner
rendez-vous dès demain pour une nouvelle
action spectaculaire le gouvernement
refusant de bouleverser les grands
équilibres économiques pourraient
renforcer tout de même un certain nombre
d' aide d'urgence comme pour aider par
exemple les familles surendettées qui
sont en constante augmentation en france
non plus seulement à propos des dépenses
de biens d'équipement mais des charges
essentiels comme les traites et les
remboursements de prêts immobiliers ou
encore les loyers impayés elizabeth est
gelé laurent le job l'oise n'est pas
toujours une rivière aussi sereine deux
hivers de suite en 94 et 95
elle est sortie de son lit en traînant
dégâts et frais énormes pour la famille
huguenots déjà en situation précaire à
l'époque avec un salaire de 8500 francs
pour rembourser s'ils y feront de crédit
est élevé trois enfants
ils n'ont pas pu surmonter mon seul
solution suite à après avoir consulté un
conseiller juridique
ça a été de faire le dossier de
surendettement ça a pris trois mois
de toute manière pour arriver déjà au
point du sûr de faire le dossier de
surendettement c'est que derrière vous
avez déjà tous les problèmes qu'il faut
avec la banque retraite chéquier
retraits de cartes retrait de tout ce
que vous voulez avec la banque avec
toutes les maisons de crédit qui vous
relance sans s'arrêter
les ajouts supplémentaires et il faut
bien manger et s'habiller
c'est avec l'aide du secours populaire
que les humains ont attendu le
rééchelonnement de leurs bases à ça
s'est arrangé pour eux ils remboursent
maintenant 3000 francs par mois deux
fois moins qu'avant mais il ya des cas
où un nouvel échéancier ne suffit pas le
futur projet de loi prévoit un gel des
dettes pendant trois ans voire même leur
effacement dans les cas les plus
difficiles
c'est le premier représentant des
consommateurs
il n'est pas normal que des familles le
peu qu'elle touche soit uniquement pour
payer les teintes d'hier était tel
peuvent plus assumer parce que la
société aujourd'hui ne veulent pas les
moyens de s'insinuer puisqu'elles n'ont
plus d'emploi pour l'instant pas
question de pouvoir se déclarer en
faillite personnelle
une solution qui permettrait pourtant de
repartir à zéro en apurant tout de suite
toutes les dettes mais elle entraînerait
la saisie des biens est en outre elle
serait rendue publique
comme pour les entreprises si l'on en
croit un sondage ifop publié par le
magazine événements du jeudi 64 % des
français pensent que notre pays peut
connaître une explosion sociale en 1980
18 54% estiment qu'elle pourrait venir
des chômeurs le chômage n'est pas un
phénomène particulier à la france en
revanche dans notre pays
la manière de l'aborder aide
particulière dans l'histoire de ces
quarante dernières années notre regard
et notre manière d'aborder ce problème
ont évolué entre les restos du coeur
d'aujourd'hui et l'appel de l'abbé
pierre au cours de l'hiver 1954
arnaud boutet bertrand cocq jadis il n'y
avait que la soupe populaire pour
nourrir les sans logis à chaque époque
son mode de distribution
aujourd'hui les associations caritatives
s'additionnent et tente de répondre à
une demande croissante en dix ans les
restos du coeur ont multiplié par dix le
nombre de couverts qui voulaient venez
disait coluche mais ils sont trop
nombreux alors les centres doivent
limiter les entrées il m'arrive de voir
et là je me sens vraiment mal à l'aise
des changes pour être à leur place
pour être juste derrière le le triste
aulas ils sont des gens qui n'ose pas
vous regarder dans les yeux et donc
c'est l'hiver thermomètre à -15 et la
marne gelé aux portes de paris
l'hiver terrible l'hiver tragique hiver
54 le pays découvre que des hommes et
des femmes n'ont pas de toit dans la
france d'après guerre
25% des immeubles sont détruits ou
endommagés 1 million de familles
cherchent un abri après la mort d'un
enfant dans la banlieue parisienne
l'abbé pierre lance son appel une
croisade de la charité qui va récolter
en moins d'une semaine 400 millions
d'anciens ferait place le matin il a
fallu mettre sur pied organisée fruit
d'un effort immense hiver 98 des hommes
dorment encore dans la rue l'histoire
semble se répéter mais la cause du
problème diffèrent aujourd'hui c'est le
chômage qui jette
cinq cent mille français sur le trottoir
pour la première fois sans doute dans
notre histoire nous sommes entrain
collectivement de nous dire que demain
sera peut-être moins bien qu'aujourd'hui
et que nos enfants vivront moins bien
que nous le mal français celui qui ronge
la confiance en l'avenir c'est le
chômage
vingt-cinq mille demandeurs d'emploi en
trois gros million une génération plus
tard les différents gouvernements
recours aux finances publiques pour
traiter les effets de la maladie une
politique réduite aux minima sociaux
tandis que l'idée s'impose le plein
emploi c'est du passé c'est clair il y
en a pas qu'ils vont pas nous mentir que
longtemps que ça il y en a pas beaucoup
dans au moins qu'ils aient le courage de
nous faire vivre correctement
faute de mieux la société civile
organise la charité il y a les restos du
coeur il y a aussi ses associations de
défense des exclus en tous genres
d'inspiration militante minoritaires
leur action largement médiatisé ça tire
toujours plus la sympathie de l'opinion
la compassion fédère les inquiétudes
certains y voient une autre façon de
faire de la politique
la grande différence c'est qu'ils aient
lorsqu on n'évoquait le pr neta rien
c'était à huy on dirait que c'est à lui
de faire ses propres affaires de prendre
ces six revendications en main
maintenant on a affaire à des gens que
l'on considère à tort ou à raison comme
des exclus de la société
incapables de s'organiser complètement
donc on le fait un petit peu à leur
place et il devient en effet un petit
peu l'objet de la compassion
au lieu d'être le sujet de la révolte
face à l'extension du domaine de la
misère lionel jospin considère qu'il n'a
pas le choix
tenue tout à la fois de satisfaire aux
critères économiques de l'europe et de
maintenir financièrement la cohorte de
déclasser sur le seuil d'une pauvreté
tolérable
je ne sais pas a déclaré nettement qu'il
ne voulait pas que la france s'installe
dans une politique d'assistanat au
chômage mais de création d'emplois et
pour ce faire il compte beaucoup sur la
loi des 35 heures par semaine et à ce
propos plusieurs estimations sont sortis
aujourd'hui très optimistes qui tablent
sur la création d'environ 700 mille
emplois à l'échéance de 2002 le ministre
des finances dominique strauss kahn est
un peu moins optimiste alors que le
patronat de son côté prévoit plutôt la
disparition d'emplois
jean paul chapelle 480 mille emplois
créés en deux ans et le scénario retenu
par l'observatoire français des
conjonctures économiques qui a calculé
les effets de la loi sur les 35 heures
dans le même temps d'autres évaluations
commandé par le ministère du travail
table sur 700 mille emplois créés en
trois ans a bercy la direction de la
prévision a testé plusieurs hypothèses
la plus optimiste anticipe la création
de 600 mille emplois ce que je constate
c'est que dans tous les cas de figure
dans toutes les études ce sont des
centaines de milliers d'emplois et ce
serait criminel je crois de ne pas
s'engager dans cette voie dont on voit
qu'elle peut être à l'origine d'une
baisse importante du chômage
toutes ces simulations économiques
admettent pourtant l'existence d'un
scénario catastrophe si les entreprises
ne jouent pas le jeu et bloque le
processus la loi sur les 35 heures
pourrait supprimer jusqu'à 100000
emplois
ce scénario moins probable est encore le
seul retenu par le patronat hier le
président du cnpf répété son hostilité
au principe d'une loi sur les 35 heures
nous avons toujours été
contrairement à ce qu'on dit tout à fait
ouvert à condition qu'il n'y ait pas de
loi qui l'imposent
mais si les entreprises peuvent négocier
une par une de la réduction de temps de
travail nous y sommes bien entendu très
favorable si ça peut à la fois favoriser
la situation générale des salariés et
surtout à permettre à l'entreprise de
réussir lieu inconnu pour l'instant
c'est cet empressement des entreprises à
réduire le temps de travail qui fera ou
non le succès de la loi en termes de
création d'emplois un drame de la
violence hier après midi devant un
collège de gretz en seine et marne un
jeune homme de 20 ans a été tué d'un
coup de couteau dans une bagarre avec
d'autres jeunes dans la soirée la mairie
de gretz a été endommagée après les
incidents
d'autres incidents s'en sont suivies
comment venir à bout de cette violence
toutes les tentatives sont
limité mais chacune a son intérêt comme
celle de ces fameux grand frère engagé
il ya quatre ans par la ratp en région
parisienne reportage olivier galzi
bernie mériaux barak était ok donc tous
les trois vous allez tous les trois lui
c'est le grand frère des grands frères
il y a quatre ans il a commencé comme
eux aujourd'hui ils encadrent plus de 80
jeunes qui veulent s'en sortir
80 blouson bleu qui agissent dans les
bus comme médiateur avec des clients
difficiles
ouahmed le chauffeur les connaît bien et
pour cause il a lui-même été grand frère
pendant deux ans à l'heure pour les
nouveaux il veut donner l'exemple
on nous prenait pour des chefs de bandes
et des anciens des anciens dealer enfin
bref ça c'est l'idée qu'on donnait des
grands frères ce qu'il ya c'est que à
nous prouver que c'était le contraire
à nous de prouver que le travail qu'on
faisait et il nous intéressait que c'est
vraiment on était des dealers ont
resterez pas pour la somme qui était
celle des grands frères quoi parce qu'il
ya des jeunes qui peuvent le voir à
l'extérieur et se dire dans leur tête
que abacha
si lui l'a réussi moi je pourrais y
aller aussi pourquoi pas renié madou lui
n'a pas eu la chance de mohamed
cela fait déjà quatre ans qui les grands
frères quatre ans payés au smic
ce grand frère pendant quatre ans c'est
pas un peu long mais
manquait une bonne ambiance parmi nous
et on va le voir passer quoi
envie de faire autre chose maintenant
j'aimerais bien une machine s'emballe
pas trouvé 700 g
on ne va pas toute ma vie
un groupe ironique et lucide à la fois
les grands frères ne veulent pas devenir
des grands pères nous ce qu'il nous faut
c'est une porte une porte d'entrée je
veux dire avec les administrations
beaucoup de choses pour pouvoir y
accéder
et si on n'a pas ces portes là on y
accédera jamais en quatre ans 160 grands
frères sont passés par l'association
pour la citoyenneté des jeunes un sur
quatre a fini par trouver un emploi
stable
pas si mal quand on sait que la plupart
n'ont aucun diplôme
a bordeaux au procès de maurice papon
les jurés ont entendu aujourd'hui son
accusateur le plus redouté michel
slitinsky dont la famille a été déportée
et qui lui-même a échappé de justesse la
déportation pour lui il n'y a aucun
doute sur la culpabilité de l'accusé
françois privat philippe dumas le grand
jour pour michel sid un ski
l'aboutissement d'un combat personnel de
15 ans à travers un face à face avec
maurice papon
il se sent quand même désigné je suis
son adversaire je suis en première ligne
c'est que je me bats je me bats avec des
moyennes difficile à la barre michel sit
ins qui parle posément au départ dit il
mon souci n'était pas de porter plainte
mais de reconstituer la mémoire juive
sous l'occupation
ensuite je me suis dit qu'il fallait
aller plus loin maurice papon écoute et
prend des notes
puis c'est le retour sur la rafle de la
nuit du 19 octobre 1942 michel sit ins
qui en réchappent en fuyant par les
toits il ne reverra jamais plus son père
abraham déporté est mort à auschwitz
et les dessins venus il a été confronté
à deux policiers lesquels l'ont invité à
prendre une valise à se presser et a
gagné le fond d'enquêté un stationnement
en 1943 le jeune michel 18 ans rejoint
le maquis dès la libération il commence
à collecter des archives
c'est lui qui en 1981 fourni au canard
enchaîné le document accusant maurice
papon alors ministre du budget vous
savez depuis 1983
il ya eu une petite révolution on a
établi désormais que vichy avait la
responsabilité des arrestations
en fin d'audience michel sit ins qui a
évoqué une nouvelle pièce absente du
dossier signé maurice papon
elle demande le transfert ou quand de
mérignac de six grands malades
cardiaques de confession juive mutation
et nominations importantes dans la
police et la justice décidé aujourd'hui
en conseil des ministres le numéro deux
du ministère de l'intérieur claude
guéant directeur général de la police
nationale nommé préfet de franche-comté
remplacé par olivier culture quant au
procureur de paris gabriel b style est
nommé procureur à la cour d'appel d'aix
en france l'actualité internationale en
algérie une série d'attentats à
l'explosif aujourd'hui dans la capitale
alger les terroristes renoue avec une
technique qu'ils avaient abandonnés pour
perpétrer les massacres de ces derniers
mois jérôme ni jean françois renaud
c'est dans cet immeuble de la rue
didouche-mourad dans le centre d'alger
une nouvelle bombe a explosé cet
après-midi un mort et plusieurs blessés
de source policière on affirme que c'est
le poseur de bombe qui s'est tué
lui-même après avoir essayé en vain de
placer l'explosif à la sortie de
l'université voisine tout l'immeuble a
été secoué par la violence de la
déflagration
au deuxième étage
il n'y a plus de porte à l'appartement
de ces deux femmes qui sont passés à
quelques secondes de la mort
04 11 jours des milieux bien informés
d'alger craignais tous les terroristes
après avoir frappé les campagnes de
l'ouest puis l'algérois de s'attaque à
la capitale pourtant les forces de
sécurité sont sur le qui vive
deux autres bombes ont été désamorcées
aujourd'hui une troisième a explosé sans
faire de victimes grâce à une femme qui
l'avait repéré dans un marché voisin de
voir les habitants âgés vivent dans la
peur que leur ville soit à nouveau
frappé par une campagne d'attentats à la
bombe
comme lors des précédents ramadan est
aujourd'hui c'est grâce à la vigilance
des populations
le pire a pu être évité mais clinton de
nouveau en difficulté la presse
américaine fait état aujourd'hui d'une
nouvelle accusation après paula jones et
une stagiaire de la maison blanche avec
laquelle il aurait entretenu une liaison
que le président américain lui aurait
demandé de cacher en établissant un faux
témoignage le président dément en bloc
ces accusations
il ya deux semaines la nouvelle faisait
sensation une anglaise de 60 ans avait
eu un enfant de manière tout à fait
naturelle sans traitement particulier
elle devenait ainsi un véritable
phénomène mondial et bien tout était
faux mais ce qui est extraordinaire
c'est qu'elle avait réussi à tromper les
médecins et son propre compagnon londres
etienne leenhardt l'image attendrissante
de cette sexagénaire changeant son bébé
a fait le tour du monde mais ce matin la
photo s'est brouillée et de maman modèle
à 60 ans elisabeth beatles et transformé
en machiavel rien qu'un premier mensonge
il y a un peu moins d'un an cette
agricultrice galloise se rendent dans
cette clinique spécialisée elle y cache
son identité affirment qu'elle a 49 ans
et obtient une fécondation in vitro pour
laquelle l'âge limite en grand bretagne
et de 55 ans les responsables de la
clinique reconnaissait d'ailleurs ce
matin qu'il n'était pas très exigeant
sur
woods a une fin nous ne demandons pas à
nos patientes leur acte de naissance air
dont nous n'avons aucun moyen de
vérification
deuxième mensonge de retour au pays de
galles elisabeth bottle affirme à son
amant qu'il est le père naturel d'un
petit garçon à venir
et lorsqu'elle donne naissance à joseph
tous les médecins cris publiquement au
miracle le record est battu
une grossesse naturelle à 60 ans un cas
unique et une maman sincèrement heureux
il y avait plein de femmes à l'hôpital
qui avait 30 ans de moins que moi avec
tout un tas de problèmes
donc je vous dis si vous êtes en bonne
santé et en pleine forme
allez-y elle prendra le temps de vendre
son histoire à un journal dominical pour
un million de francs avant le bouquet
final la supercherie le départ de
l'amant qui pensait être le père la
confusion des médecins et le mea culpa
des médias s'ils irrésistible désir
d'être mère ne se discute pas le
scénario imaginé par elizabeth beetle
est tout de même à ranger au rayon des
histoires à dormir debout à cannes au
midem le salon de tous les
professionnels de la musique a été
publié le hit parade des plus gros
succès de vente il comporte certaines
surprises louis carzou alain location
comme dit le proverbe éclaircies sur la
croisette bénéfices dans les galettes
en clair l'industrie du disque
rassemblés pour le midem à cannes
célèbre une années 90 est exceptionnel
avec des ventes en progression de 8% et
qui dépasse désormais les 7 milliards de
francs
bref le commerce des ritournelles et des
remix est bel et bien florissant au pays
de la marseillaise et le plus étonnant
mais oui monsieur sait que nombre de
nouveaux talents ont réussi à percer
parmi les héros du hit-parade de l'année
passée ainsi le recordman toutes
catégories des ventes n'est autre que
l'inattendu andrea bocelli
m
suivi il est vrai de près par jean
jacques goldman plus habitué à
transformer le vinyle en or
choquée
seul bémol au tableau le marché de la
musique classique lui stagne pour la
troisième année consécutive et ne
représente désormais qu'à peine 7% des
ventes de disques en france
de fait la grande musique a aussi de
grands coûts de production ce qui rend
plus difficile l'émergence d'un nouveau
répertoire et de nouveaux
enregistrements
ensuite on peut aussi se poser la
question sur les nouveautés du lancement
d'un jeune talent pour lequel on va
vendre le disent presque 120 ou 130
francs alors qu'une réédition de 6 à
tesla richter ou de rubinstein
quelquefois se vend 50 60 70 francs et
pour l'année 98 et les suivantes les
menaces qui planent sur l'industrie du
disque viendront tout ou presque du
problème de la distribution en passe
d'être totalement chamboulée par
internet et les radios numériques autant
de supports ou les musiques disponibles
en qualité comme en quantité échappe à
tout contrôle commercy demain vous avez
une radio qui en son numérique passe en
permanence l'ensemble des chansons de
jacques brel
pourquoi le consommateur va aller
acheter l'intégrale e jacques brel il
branchera sur la radio pour peu que la
radio campus lui dise à quel heure tel
titre passe et tout à coup le disque
s'écroule
certes il est sans doute un peu tôt pour
écrire le faire-part du disque mais
cette industrie qui représente 600 mille
emplois en europe est à la veille de
profonds bouleversements et là
contrairement aux proverbes personne ne
connaît la chanson
on connaît depuis aujourd'hui les
nominations aux prochains césars du
cinéma le plus nominé alain resnais pour
son film on connaît la chanson juste
devant le bossu de philippe de broca
stéphane haumant à frédéric bazille la
bataille va être rude pour le bossu
daniel merkel dans la catégorie meilleur
acteur face à lui on faisait du soulier
qui connaît la chanson et de surprises
alain chabat cabotine dans didier lafay
timsit à contre emploi en sombre cousin
d'alain corneau charles berling minutes
pour nettoyage à sec accompagne sa
partenaire l'étonnante mieux mieux elles
ont quitté la catégorie espoirs sandrine
kiberlain dans le 7ème ciel
et marie gillain dans le bossu mais
sabine azéma donnent de la voix
avec 12 nominations on connaît la
chanson part favori d'autant que rennais
est un grand habitué du palmarès
aujourd'hui le cinquième élément de luc
besson et le bossu représentent les
super productions françaises les il
faudra compter avec les petits western
marius et jeannette toit pour les films
étrangers c'est l'année des anglais les
virtuoses émouvant de full monty amusant
ou ceux très classique patient anglais
qui valut un oscar à juliette binoche
haute couture et et 98 aujourd'hui celui
qui reste le plus grand créateur de ces
quarante dernières années
yves saint laurent le maître est celui
qui se considère comme son élève il l'a
dit lui-même jean paul gaultier sophie
mais elle bernard connor quand on a la
chance d'être accueillis au 5 avenue
marceau on sait que l'on rentre dans le
saint des saints
monsieur saint laurent en blouse blanche
est absorbée par une séance de travail
quasi religieuse on murmure que le
couturier que l'on sait fragile comme un
souffle va mieux même si sa voix est
encore hésitante
j'ai perdu 15 kilos mais je vais le trac
oui beaucoup parce que c'est une
collection comme une autre parce que
c'est vous 40 ans de création ça devient
tout de suite autre chose non j'ai pas
pensé à mes 40 ans de création quand je
le fais il célèbre pourtant ce mois de
janvier 40 ans de succès et sa 80ème
collection haute couture dont une
dizaine pour dior à ses tout débuts
les collections se succèdent et toujours
le même style immuable si ce n'est ce
détail infime ici une épaule pagode
courbée vers l'extérieur qui signe la
saison
j'ai mis quarante ans à me trouver et
parfois je cherche encore dit saint
laurent il demeure le maître a contesté
celui que des générations de couturiers
vénère
mouassa n'auront celui que toutes les
bases de la de la mode actuelle et
de la mode actuelle de la mode de plus
de 2,2 plein d'années enfin je veux dire
les vingt dernières vaultier est un
classique sous sa carapace d'excentrique
digne héritier d'yves saint laurent ils
défilent même sous le regard de sa muse
catherine deneuve
il n'empêche qu'il traverse aussi la
mode avec humour et provoque une
rencontre inattendue entre mozart et les
touareg et quand même
j'espère actuelle et
d'aujourd'hui qu'on s'est revus et
corrigés simplement l'atmosphère comme
ça et pour certaines silhouettes ils ont
ça peut évoquer soin du petit marquié ou
des coudes et des hommes bleus à sa
première collection haute couture jean
paul gaultier doutait une saison pour
essayer disait-il
et après advienne que pourra un an et
demi plus tard il a trouvé sa place et
vous il le regard
et
et pour accompagner ces modèles
magnifique une visite à une exposition
qui sera inaugurée demain à la tour
montparnasse à paris exposition qui rend
hommage aux meilleurs créateurs de
parure en diamants extraordinaire vous
allez voir mais ne parlons pas du prix
nicole canlers langlois luc bachofen
carats par milliers dans cette
chorégraphie insolite à l'opéra comique
pour les oscars des diamants évocation
sensuelle prouesse technique et même des
réalisations futuriste et parmi les 25
brillant lauréat du monde entier les
trois français dont moteur de ce collier
hermine
je me suis inspiré pascal en fourrure il
fallait pour moi que je visualise le
volume 2 de la fourrure donc j'ai pris
des allumettes que j'ai disposé sur une
plastie line pour avoir en volumes assez
conséquents et bien disposé les diamants
pour ce soit le plus étincelant possible
660 diamants d'un poids de 50 7 carats
monté sur leurs cris chaque diamant est
serti sur une tige la base est articulé
pour épouser l'encolure est donnée
légèreté souplesse autres pièces primées
la bague méridienne de christine et cher
un diamant taille émeraude de deux
carats repose sur une volute d'ébène 96
autre diamant monté sur platine complète
ce surprenant mélange jeté négligemment
sur le dos ce collier modifiable à
souhait tout à coup j'ai commencé à
comprimer diamant jan steen attends je
suis déjà 350 diamant on va rajouter 15
pour en avoir 365 symboliquement
ces étoiles on les retrouvait dans ce
gala on diamanté certaine les possédait
d'autres les avaient emprunté mais vous
pouvez déjà fait prendre deux fois jours
si les mains avec la sortie cette
semaine d'un film américain de
science-fiction starship trooper le
titre ne donne qu'une mauvaise
indication du contenu puisqu'il s'agit
tout simplement si je puis dire de
l'invasion de la planète par des
araignées géantes cauchemar garantie
stéphane haumant
une invasion d'araignées géantes comme
dans une série b des années 50
si ce déferlement est possible au grand
jour c'est évidemment grâce aux effets
spéciaux d'aujourd'hui
starship troopers de paul verhoeven joue
avec nos peurs d'enfant
les araignées les hommes c'est une
vieille histoire d'une phobie rampante
c'est un dur mais les insectes
c'était vraiment content qu'on les
rachète après dans l'essonne croisement
improbable d'araignée de scorpions et de
punaises les héroïnes du film ont dévoré
l'essentiel du budget 100 millions de
dollars toujours plus cher toujours plus
efficace entre films d'horreur et film
de guerre les comédiens se battaient
donc sur le plateau contre des ennemis
virtuels ambiance gi's garantie avec
l'adjudant verhoven le réalisateur
venaient vers nous ils criaient je suis
la reine y est je suis l'araignée ça
nous rendait dingue on était à cran
alors on dégommer les bestioles même
s'ils n'étaient pas là ça va c'était
assez facile en fait ont tué notre
metteur en scène
c'est assez agréable pour toi fiston
l'infanterie choix bravo mon vieux c'est
l'infanterie mobile qui a fait de moi
l'homme que je suis aujourd'hui
la société des hommes version starship
troopers est un état totalitaire et
militariste les héros qui sacrifient
leur vie pour sauver le monde portent
des uniformes de sinistre mémoire
quelques critiques accusent verhoven de
faire l'apologie du fascisme lui
rétorque mon film est ironique utilise
l'image du fascisme c'est vrai mais
c'est pour dire au public certaines
choses montrées dans ce film je doive
être prise avec beaucoup de méfiance
provocation violence extrême c'est la
patte de verhoeven
vous voilà prévenus si vous avez choisi
ces araignées pour vous faire une toile
sport tennis et internationaux
d'australie ça marche plutôt bien pour
les français santoro pioline qualifié
l'américain s'en passe également aidé le
deuxième tout une bataille entre les
deux nouvelles stars du tennis féminin
mondial
les soeurs williams françois baroin
d'ordinaire le monde impitoyable du
tennis féminin c'est plutôt crêpage de
chignon et compagnie mais les soeurs
williams c'est pas pareil d'abord à
cause des perles
elles peuvent pas faire de chimio
ensuite au lieu de se détester
cordialement venus la grande ici au
premier plan et serena la petite là bas
au fond du court ça dort chacune d'elles
vous le dira la future numéro un mondial
c'est sûr c'est l'autre ce qui ne veut
pas dire qu'elles sont prêtes à faire
des cadeaux la preuve pour la première
fois en exclusivité mondiale les filles
de madame williams se savent compter
rémy passé à melbourne pour ne pas créer
de problèmes familiaux le droit
d'aînesse a été respectée venus 17 ans a
battu serré 16 ans en deux sets en bonne
américaine
elles n'ont pas oublié les bons
sentiments la tournée des williams
sisters ne fait que commencer
retour à la politique le premier
ministre monsieur d un jospin s'exprimer
ce soir chez nos confrères de tf1 il a
pris un certain nombre d'engagements
dont les principaux sont les suivants
rattrapage de l'allocation spécifique de
solidarité qui n'a pas été réévalué
depuis 1994 un effort de solidarité même
de la part des entreprises mais pas
question a répété donc comme à
l'assemblée nationale hier le premier
nice pas les est question de laisser
dériver les minima sociaux on écoute ne
laisse pas le premier engagement c'est
que je ne laisserai pas les minimas
sociaux dérivés il n'est pas normal
qu'un certain nombre de minima sociaux
est en tout cas l'allocation spécifique
de solidarité pour les chômeurs en fin
de droit n'est pas suivi le rythme de la
hausse des prix il faudra donc ces
minima sociaux les indexé sur le cours
de l'efs
un peu comme on le fait pour le smic par
exemple deuxième engagement oui par
exemple deuxième engagement
je ferai en sorte que le rattrapage de
la ss qui n'avait pas été revalorisée
par le précédent gouvernement depuis
1994 que ce rattrapage
de là et c'est ce que nous avons amorcé
se fasse intégralement ses deuxièmes
engagements relativement est donc aussi
rétroactivement et d'ailleurs les
premières mesures que nous avons prises
sont rétroactives je ferai en sorte
aussi que au delà de ce rattrapage un
effort supplémentaire soit fait en
faveur des chômeurs de longue durée qui
sont dans les situations les plus
difficiles ou éventuellement des jeunes
c'est à dire qu'il va falloir que grâce
au travail de madame thérèse juin
lambert et au travail avec les
associations nous ciblions bien les
situations les plus difficiles
et pour ces cas là il faudra faire un
effort supplémentaire au delà du
rattrapage c'est à dire un accroissement
voilà donc pour l'essentiel de ce qu'a
dit le premier ministre votre
commentaire arlette et d'écouté c'est
vrai que ce soir il y avait deux
objectifs mais j'espère le premier
objectif c'est évidemment de tenter de
mettre un terme au mouvement des
chômeurs alors vous l'avez dit c'est
vrai que le cadre général avait tout à
fait le même
il n'est pas question d'accéder aux
revendications des chômeurs ça coûterait
trop cher aux finances publiques pas
question de creuser le déficit pas
question d'augmenter les impôts des
français et monsieur jospin dit qu'on ne
peut pas dire non évidemment aux
chômeurs mais on ne peut pas dire oui et
faire tout tout de suite alors c'est
vrai qu'il se donne un peu de temps
il prend des engagements il y aura une
augmentation notamment de cette
allocation spécifique de solidarité mais
il veut d'abord que tout le système
comme il l'a demandé à des spécialistes
madame juin lambert soit remise à plat
au fonds l'essentiel on ne trouvera sans
doute dans cette loi d'exclusion qui
sera discutée à l'assemblée très vite
sans doute au certainement d'ailleurs au
mois de mars prochain
voilà pour le premier point deuxième
souci de monsieur j'ose pas eh bien
c'est effectivement de reprendre
l'offensive sortir de cette position un
peu de défense et de contre-attaquer et
bien évidemment le gros objectif
et bien c'est la réduction du temps de
travail et le débat sur les 35 heures
qui commencera la semaine prochaine
avantage évidemment les 35 heures c'est
que ça mobilise bien la gauche était une
revendication commune et ça fera un très
bon thème commun pour les élections
région
il faut remarquer aussi ce soit l'appel
solennel lancé par le premier ministre
aux entreprises donc le patronat n'est
pas l'adversaire on fera pression sur
lui et on demande en tout cas à ses
patrons de prendre leurs responsabilités
et de participer à l'effort en faveur de
l'emploi rappel important de la
philosophie du premier ministre il veut
une société de l'emploi et pas une
société d'assistance alors au total
eh bien on le voit bien discours de
gauche du premier ministre rattrapage
des erreurs des maladresses de ces
dernières semaines mais plus que jamais
en fonction des engagements et du cap
qu'il a tracé ce soir et bien évidemment
on l'attend sur des résultats il faut
notamment que ses 35 heures crée des
emplois
merci a relaté je vous invite tout de
suite que monsieur philippe seguin le
président du rpr sera ici même sur ce
plateau demain soir pour répondre en
quelque sorte aux propos de lionel
jospin avant nous quittez donc le rappel
des principaux titres mis à part
monsieur lionel jospin de l'actualité de
ce mercredi cuba donc dans moins de deux
heures maintenant le pape jean paul ii
et atterrira à la havane la
réconciliation attendue entre l'église
catholique et le régime de fidel castro
dans un instant la météo sophie davant
avec un peu de retard dû à l'actualité
nous en excusons 20h à 21h plus
exactement chez ma tante un film de
télévision français avec comme vedette
claire nadeau demain 7h 50 dans les 4
vérités
françoise laborde recevra alain madelin
13 heures patrick chêne et puis demain
soir je vous retrouverai ici même à 20
heures je vous souhaite une excellente
soirée sur notre prochaine bonsoir
ce soir sur fond